In this video, let us look at
a second quantity of interest
that has to do with
absorbing states.
Now that we know
how to calculate
the probability of getting
to a given absorbing state,
we would like to know how long
it would take to get to it.
Let us first deal
with that question
when we have only
one absorbing state.
Let us consider the
following Markov chain, which
is a little simpler
than the one that we
had in the previous video.
We have transient states.
One, two, and three
are transient states.
And we have one
recurrent state, four.
And that recurrent state
four is an absorbing state,
because once you get to
it you stay there forever.
So in this simple example, the
absorption probability to four
is trivially one.
No matter where you start,
with probability one
you're guaranteed that
eventually you will reach four.
But the question of
interest is to know
how long would it
take to get to four.
In other words, how
many transitions
would you have to do
until you reach four?
Of course we don't know.
It is a random variable.
In fact, it's more than
one random variable.
It would depend probably
on where you started.
Starting from two,
one, or three, or four,
would lead to different
random variables.
We are going to be
interested in looking
at their expectation,
or the expected value
of these random variables.
More precisely, let us define
exactly what we want to do,
which is to find the expected
number of transitions--
that we're going to
call him Mu of i--
until reaching four, which
is our absorbing state,
given that the initial state
is i, one of these four states.
First as a warm up, let's
do some quick calculation.
If you didn't have this
part here, and instead
we were looking just
at this portion here.
Make this one
disappear like this,
and replace it by a
loop of probability 0.8.
So now if you start from state
two, with probability 0.2
you will go to four,
or with probability 0.8
you will remain in two.
And now you ask yourself,
what is the number
of trials you have to
do until you reach four?
Well we know what it is.
This is a geometric
random variable
with the probability
of success, which
is a success being
going to four, of 0.2.
So the expected number of
trials, starting from two,
that you will have to go
through until you reach four,
will be 1 over this probability.
So 1/0.2, which is 5.
Now that we have done
this quick calculation,
it should be clear that if we
go back to the previous Markov
chain that we had here,
the expected time, Mu 2,
would probably be bigger than 5.
Since from two, not only
you have the probability
of going to four,
but you might have
some chance of traveling there.
So probably the number of
times until you reach four
would be bigger than 5.
Let's see.
Well, first of all, if you
start at four, the expected
number of transitions
until reaching four
would obviously be zero.
So here, for i equals
4, you indeed get zero.
What about for the others?
Well again, this is what
we would like to calculate.
How are we going to do that?
Well, the argument
is going to be
of the same nature as the
one that we used before.
We are going to think
in terms of tree,
and consider possible options
starting from a given state.
So let's do this
calculation from two.
So you are in two, and we're
going to build that tree here.
So you are in state two.
What could happen next?
Well, you can either
transition to four
with the probability 0.2.
Or with probability
0.8, you end up in one.
And you have done
one transition here.
So plus one transition.
So you are interested
in calculating Mu 2.
After one transition you either
end up in four, in that case
you stop, you're done.
In other words the
resulting value
here would be Mu 4,
which we know is 0.
Or you are in one.
And now, given that
you are in one,
you want to find the expected
number of transitions
until reaching four, which
is exactly defined here.
So here what you have is Mu 1.
And now you can use the
total expectation theorem
to put all of these
things together.
What it means is
that Mu 2 will be 1,
and you have one transition.
And then after you do that
transition with probability
0.2, you know that you're
going to be in four.
And the expected
value then will be
Mu 4 plus 0.8, which
is the probability that
end up in state one.
And conditional on that, the
remaining expected iterations
until reaching
four will be Mu 1.
Now this one is of course
0, so what you end up with
is 1 plus 0.8 Mu 1.
So you get a relation
between Mu 2 and Mu 1.
Now you can do the same
thing if you start from one
or start from three.
So let's do it again from one.
So you're interested in one.
After one transition, so
plus one, what happened?
Well, with the probability
0.6, you end up in two.
And with the probability
0.4, you end up in three.
And from three, if you
start in state three,
after one transition
what happened?
Well, with the probability 0.5
you would end up in state one.
And then the expected number
of transitions from state one
until reaching
four will be Mu 1.
Or with probability
0.5, you end up in two.
So again here, if you
look at these three here,
this is a system
of three equations,
three linear equations
with three unknowns.
It has a unique solution.
I will let you do
the calculation,
let me give you the result.
What you obtain is
Mu 1 will be 110/8.
And the reason I'm
writing it this way
is so that we can compare them.
Mu 2 will be 96/8, which is 12.
And Mu 3 is 111/8.
So here again, a
quick sanity check,
the number that we get here, 12,
is indeed bigger than the five
that we have obtained when
we restricted ourselves
to this set.
So we do have Mu
2 greater than 5.
Now as the relative value
between Mu 1, Mu 2, and Mu 3,
it sort of makes sense.
Mu 2, the state two, is
the one closest to four,
it is the one actually
linked to four.
So in some sense,
the expected number
of transitions to
reach four will always
be the smallest one, because
starting from the other states,
you will have to go to
two before going to four.
And in general, if you
have a general Markov chain
with transient states
and one absorbing state,
and you're asking yourself,
what is the expected time
to absorption to that
unique absorbing state,
it will be the unique solution
from the system of equations
given here.
Where the pij are the transition
probabilities of your Markov
chain.
Now we have seen how to
solve this problem when
we have one unique
absorbing state.
What happens if you have more
than one absorbing state?
Like for example, in this case.
Well, first of
all, a quick note.
You realize here that you have
one, two, and three, three
transition states.
And indeed here, you have
four as an absorbing state,
it's a recurrent state,
and once you get to it
you stay there forever.
And five is also a recurrent
state, and once you get to five
you stay there forever.
So four and five are
both absorbing states.
And in a previous
video, we had seen
how to calculate the probability
of ending up in four,
as opposed to ending up in five.
What we know is that the
probability of ending up
in four plus the probability
of ending up in five will be 1.
But since the probability of
ending up in four is not 1,
trying to find the
expected number of steps
until you reach
four specifically
does not make much sense.
That expectation of that random
variable is a random variable,
but that expectation
will be infinity.
Why?
Because there is a
positive probability
that you will end up in five.
And if you end up in
five, once you get there,
the number of steps to go
to four will be infinity.
So it makes more sense
to think about what
is the expected time
to any absorbing state.
So to either four or five.
Now If you're interested
in that quantity,
one trick in order to solve
that problem using the technique
that we have seen so far, is to
combine four and five into one
mega state, call
it whatever, six.
Right?
And six is a combination
of four and five.
It's a big absorbing state.
And once you're in
six, you stay in six.
And now you just have
to define exactly what
is the probability of
transition from one, two,
and three, to that mega state.
Well here from two, you
had, originally, two arcs.
You're going to combine
these two into one arc,
and you're going to sum
these probabilities.
So you had 0.3 and 0.2.
You put in here 0.5.
And on this arc you had only one
arc, so you maintain that arc.
And you have that
probability that you had,
which I believe was 0.2.
Now you go back, if you
look at the situation now,
it's very close to the
one that we have here.
All right?
See this four that you
have here is the six.
Now of course, you have
another arc here like that,
but that's fine.
You can stay add the arc
here and put it as 0.2.
And then you reduce
this one to 0.3
to make it square with here.
But the idea on how to solve
that is identical to this one.
You would have to change
a little bit of this,
but this is the same technique.
So in the end, we
have seen a technique
to find the expected time
to absorptions whenever
you have absorbing states
in a given Markov chain.